bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo je sors de chambly et
comme le veut la tradition on va faire
une petite vidéo d'analysé surtout de
théorie très ravi du résultat je vous
avoue que j'étais curieux sur comment
chang cheese pourrait se créer une place
parmi cet océan de de multivers deux
dimensions de cosmic qu'essayent
d'instaurer la phase iv et franchement
bas il ya plein de choses à dire c'est
plutôt bien fait donc voilà je suis très
content néanmoins je préfère vous
prévenir évidemment la vidéo va spoil
sévère le film ainsi nous voulons
traiter de toutes les informations des
théories et c'est donc voilà si vous
n'avez pas vu le film on vous faites
comme vous voulez mais vous êtes
prévenus et bien évidemment je vais vous
proposer ma vision personnelle du film
et surtout de sa fin et de ce qui peut
s'en dégager pour la suite des
événements tout d'abord s'il ya bien une
première choses intéressantes à dire
concernant le personnage de chan chee
c'est que on ne sait pas quand est ce
qu'il va réapparaître dans le mcv alors
que pourtant les films de la phase 4
c'est un secret pour personne sont
plutôt disposé à réunir les
protagonistes est plutôt lié les
histoires entre elles et cetera comme
par exemple bas spider man 3 avec doctor
strange de et c'est lié aussi à oujda
vision puis à loki etc bref et ce n'est
pas du tout anodin car au vu de la fin
de chantilly et de sa scène post
générique
la grande question c'est bien et
maintenant qu'est ce qu'il va se passer
pour chan chee et ses dix anneaux donc
c'est que marvel comme toujours et c'est
tout à fait normal nous cache pas mal de
choses concernant leur nouveau héros
nouveau héros qui est censé avoir une
grande place pour l'avenir du mc hugh
puisqu'il vient d'être introduit avec
une belle origin story et là où c'est
plus marquant c'est concernant ces
fameux dix anneaux puisque là où le mc
ur est un tant soit peu fidèle aux
comics même s'il ya de l'art écriture et
qu'il remanie certaines choses et bien
ici c'est vraiment le flou total
les dix anneaux qui symbolise le mac
plus fine du film donc l'objet au centre
du récit ne nous apportent aucune
information sur et bien leur origine et
c'est là toute l'intrigué de chambishi
concernant son avenir je veux dire même
la deuxième scène post générique ne nous
dit pas chante she will return mais
carrément les designers reviendront bon
évidemment vu que c'est sa soeur qui a
repris le flambeau de l'organisation on
se doute que ça parle de ça mais quand
même il y a une double lecture nous
savons que nous serons amenés à revoir
les dix anneaux eux mêmes qui font
l'objet d'un grand mystère mystère dont
chan chee semble être le gardien est
celui qui va déceler la vérité puisqu'il
lui appartiennent et lui obéissent en
quelque sorte d'ailleurs fun fact par
rapport à ça cette scène post générique
fait énormément et qu iron man 1 kevin
fait guy l'a lui même confirmé
évidemment dans les comics iron man est
le plus grand ennemi du mandarin nous y
retrouvons à certaines hommage mais
surtout cela traduit la position de
champion qui sert de point de repère en
tant que nouveau héros qui arrive dans
cette nouvelle phase au milieu de choses
qui le dépasse totalement en tant que
simple terriens et pour aller un peu
plus dans le détail la scène post
générique est très bien amené parce que
et plein de petits détails qui sont
importants enfin personnellement je
trouve par exemple pourquoi ou wang
captain marvel et banner pour analyser
les anneaux wang va servir de référence
pour chan chee dans ce nouveau monde
qu'il va découvrir comme un médiateur un
peu comme à l'époque avec iron man
unique fiori justement nick fury a
toujours servi de base d'informations le
mec qui connaît déjà tous les aspects de
ce qui semble inimaginable pour le
nouveau héros est d'ailleurs la scène
expliquerait aussi l'absence de wang
dans spider man 3 le moment où il semble
partir dans le trailer avec ce qui s'est
passé avec les 10 à nos échanges shi
huang va accompagner le nouveau héros
dans sa quête pour découvrir les
origines des dix anneaux et qui les
appels du coup et concernant banner et
carole banner est entre guillemets la
nouvelle grosse tête des avengers depuis
la mort de toni donc banner est la
référence on va dire scientifique
terrienne pour analyser les anneaux et
carole vient justement compléter
l'analyse avec plutôt un point de vue
cosmique nous avons tendance à l'oublier
mais captain marvel règle des conflits
dans l'espace depuis plus de 30 ans elle
possède un savoir et une expérience liée
à l'espace qui est très importante pour
les avengers et justement c'est là que
c'est intéressant puisque le savoir
terriens représenté par banner et le
savoir cosmique de l'espace représenté
par carole et bien n'arrive pas à
déceler la vérité sur les dix anouk tout
ce que nous savons par rapport au film
c'est qu'ils sont très anciens même plus
d'un millénaire ils sont composés d'un
matériau inconnu que même carole qui
pourtant devrait connaître un nom de
matériaux extraterrestres ne reconnaît
même pas et surtout ils produisent une
énergie démesurée et qu'on n'a même pas
encore conscience je pense puisque même
wang l'a senti depuis k-mart âge alors
que c'est pourtant à l'autre bout de la
planète et ah oui sans oublier les
anneaux fonctionne aussi comme des
balises en émettant un signal appelant
quelqu'un ou quelque chose évidemment
cette réécriture n'est pas anodine comme
je vous le disais marvel nous cache
quelque chose et il y a quelque chose
avec ses dix anneaux car le truc c'est
que si on se tourne vers les comics et
bien les dix anneaux sont d'origine
extraterrestre et appartiendrait à un
très vieux peuple de dragon de l'espace
on va dire dont un vaisseau aurait
atterri sur terre et que le mandarin
aurait trouvé les designers en ferme
d'ailleurs l'homme de dix guerriers
cosmique très puissant et c'est ce qui
leur donne leur pouvoir d'ailleurs
normalement chaque anneau possède un
pouvoir spécifique du genre un cas lié à
la télépathie un autre à l'eau etc etc
et tout ça on ne le retrouve pas dans le
film et pour être honnête je ne pense
pas qu'on va le retrouver à l'avenir non
plus à part peut-être de trois éléments
tout simplement car déjà le mandarin n'a
pas trouvé de vaisseau quand il a eu les
dix anneaux il a été fait mention d'un
cratère dans la légende donc l' origine
extraterrestre se tient toujours mais
bon que ce soit lié à des dragons de
l'espace je sais pas vous mais je n'y
crois pas trop pour le moment là dans le
mc eu surtout au vu de tout ce qu'il ya
à venir mais surtout la grosse
différence c'est que les anneaux
d'anchamps chi semble plus fonctionner
comme un artefact propre et unique comme
s'il ne faisait qu'un nous n'avons pas
retrouvé de pouvoir propre à chaque
anneau mais bon c'est possiblement un
aspect qui pourrait arriver plus tard
pour l'opep franchit en terme de pouvoir
je ne vais pas vous mentir j'ai
possiblement deux petites idées là deux
petits théorie qui collerait bien du
coup pour les origines des anneaux et
l'avenir du mc eu et c'est la première
idée serait qu'il soit lié à
quang le conquérant alors ok ça paraît
peut-être un petit peu incongru dit
comme ça mais attendez en fait il est
dit qu ils sont très anciens mais du
coup ils sont impossible à dater et que
ni captain marvel ni banner ne comprenne
comment il fonctionne et de quoi ils
sont composés donc du coup l'idée de
kong n'est pas à négliger nous le savons
kang est destiné à devenir le vilain
emblématique de marvel dans les
prochaines années et là où c'est
pertinent c'est que kang s'est forgée de
nombreuses armes lors de son arrivée au
40e siècle en gros pour résumer avant de
devenir kang nathaniel richard's en tant
que rama tout a souhaité retourner à
l'époque moderne sauf qu'il a fini par
erreur dans un futur très très lointain
et ce futur lui a apporté de nombreux
matériaux inconnus qui lui ont permis de
se créer des armes très très futuriste
et ses armes très futuriste et même son
armure qui est aussi très très futuriste
bas des fois c'est un petit peu
déconcertant même pour les avengers
puisque ces composés de matériaux qui
sont situées beaucoup trop loin dans le
temps et justement suite à ses
nombreuses conquêtes à travers le temps
avec son équipement du 40e siècle il
aurait pu soit perdre ses anneaux qui
l'aurait créé dans le passé ou bien ils
les auraient laissés là où le mandarin
aurait pu les trouver pour justement
influencer le passé à devenir un futur
bien précis où il a besoin que le
mandarin devienne ce qu'il est devenu
est-ce que vous captez l'idée et du coup
cela permettrait de raccrocher chan chee
à loki celui qui demeure et c'est tout
le tralala quoi sinon deuxième idée
quand on parle de la phase 4 du mc eu on
voit souvent directement les liens dans
la timeline du style spider man 3 qui
est lié à doctor strange de mais qui
aussi lié à oujda vision à la base puis
il ya aussi loki qui vient se greffer là
dedans etc mais il existe je trouve deux
films qui sont un peu perdus au milieu
de tout ça c'est chan chee et les
ethernet et quand j'ai vu la scène post
générique je me suis posé la question
est-ce que les réponses ne se trouverait
pas dans les éternels la première chose
serait l'aspect esthétique des dix
anneaux ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que les éternels sont un peu différents
de ce qu'on a l'habitude de voir que ce
soit dans les costumes et surtout dans
les pouvoirs et les armes il y a un
aspect très épuré et divin dans les
éternels des êtres qui débarque de
l'espace pour guider et protéger
l'humanité est ce que vous voyez ce que
je veux dire et l'idée que les dix
anneaux seraient des objets liés aux
éternels expliquerait également leur
ancienneté puisque comme vous le savez
les éternels sont présents sur terre
depuis l'aube de l'humanité dans les
comics et pour le mc vue il était fait
mention de 7000 ans je crois je me
trompe peut-être dans la date mais voilà
wang qui affirme que les anneaux ont
largement plus de mille ans et bien ça
colle bien avec les éternels éternelle
qui sont d'ailleurs très discret et qui
viennent de l'espace donc les anneaux
trouvait dans un cratère par le mandarin
ce soi-disant ne sachant pas leur
origine est bien avec un peu de recul
cela colle bien aussi surtout que les
éternels sont 10es il y a dix anneaux
dix anneaux qui dans le mc eu ont un
pouvoir combiner qui fait qu'ils sont
surpuissants utilisés ensemble et et
chez les éternels nous savons via les
comics qu'une fois qu'ils sont groupés
ils peuvent réaliser de très grandes
choses comme invoqué un youzhny mind une
entité qui résulte de la fusion des
pouvoirs de plusieurs éternelle et
d'ailleurs étant donné que les designers
normalement un pouvoir unique différents
des uns des autres et bien c'est un peu
la même chose pour les éternels qui ont
tous des aptitudes différentes si les
anneaux sont bel et bien lié à eux ils
pourraient révéler la véritable
puissance de ces artefacts ce qui
permettrait de faire évoluer changer en
un héros encore plus puissant qu'il ne
l'est déjà mais dans tous les cas cela
permettrait de lier les éternels
échanges schiever un avenir commun là où
d'autres héros ont déjà des récits tout
tracé que nous connaissons déjà sachant
qu'en plus il est fait mention que les
anneaux font l'effet d'une balise qui
appellerait quelqu'un ou quelque chose
est bien l'idée qu'ils appellent leur
propriétaire les éternels ou si nous
voulons aller encore plus loin les
célestes carrément qu'ils sont censés
arriver sur terre prochainement et bien
cela permettrait de faire une première
rencontre entre les éternels et les
avengers les dévoilant au grand jour
enfin voila je pense m'arrêter là
malheureusement je n'ai plus de place
dans ma caméra donc je vais continuer en
voix off je suis très content de vous
avoir fait une petite vidéo spéculations
autour de shang chi le film était très
sympa et nous propose des mystères
vraiment intéressant et du coup pas si
la vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner nous avons plein de sujets à
traiter ensemble puis n'oubliez pas le
petit pouce bleus à laisser un petit
commentaire sur ce que vous avez pensé
du film et je profite également de vous
avoir pour vous dire que je serai
présent aux anges et geek festival le 11
et 12 septembre avec les braults heroes
sef et mestre thibout on sera très
heureux de voir certains et certaines
d'entre vous si vous y êtes et puis
voilà que le lionheart soit avec vous
écoutez cet argot rock allez ciao tout
le monde
[Musique]